what have you learned about use amongst
young men and how they feel about it I
think news is one of the most
misunderstood things from a clinical
perspective from a psychological
perspective from a neuroscience
perspective so the first thing that's
really interesting is that people who
are addicted
oftentimes get exposed at a very young
age second thing is that point usage has
nothing to do with perversion a lot of
people think if someone is really
addicted they must be like really
there's research that shows that it
really has nothing to do with which is
what's weird there's a research that did
a multivariate regression analysis on
people addicted which means they looked
at which variable Associates the most
with usage and the number one variable
was meaninglessness so the more
meaningless your life is the more likely
you are to be addicted like you have to
have a reason to stop watching you have
to go through that withdrawal for some
greater good and so helping people find
purpose is like one of the biggest
things that apparently helps with